in hong kong three prominent activists
have pleaded guilty as a trial begins
over their involvement in last year's
pro-democracy protests
joshua wong ivan lamb and agnes chao are
all expecting jail terms
for inciting and organizing an
unauthorized assembly
the charges are related to a protest
outside of police headquarters in june
of last year
hong kong's pro-democracy movement has
faltered since beijing imposed a
sweeping national security law on the
territory
that severely restricted political
speech
joshua wong has now been remanded in
custody but before entering
court he had a message of defiance for
supporters
neither prison boss nor election bans
nor
any other arbitrary power will stop us
from activism
what we are doing now is to explain the
value of freedom
to the world through our compassion to
whom we love
so much that we are willing to sacrifice
the freedom of our own
i'm prepare for the fin chance
of walking free may god bless hong kong
and we will continue to fight for
freedom and now it's not the time for us
khao tao to beijing
and to surrender thank you